well no they're not groupies like that
you know listen when they're latinas i
had more people that wanted to feed me
than [ __ ] me
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
where do you play ball or you know did
you play in college did you
did you get letters did you play in
italy
and maybe he didn't but when somebody's
that tall you don't see people that's
all
every day yeah and your just assumption
is
this dude you know plays ball
yeah well i think too if like if you're
seven feet tall it's like
10 of the seven footers in the world
just are in the nba
like the odds are that good yeah
and how bad that did our well that's not
about basketball
but how bad did our taller seven foot
community was when somebody from europe
was considered no good like they would
say man we got some dude from
croatia playing oh [ __ ] that dude can't
play no he's good man
and and they're good like they don't
miss and
you know there was the guy that got
unfortunately was in the car accident
and uh
oh yeah hey do like they do
do like they do and hey do like he does
to the kid lock his ass out
who decided to show up
be here at the right time or don't be
here at all
tell him come on
just for that you have to drink three
beers today
liza is uh um oh she'll understand this
one a maven she's a maven
of the world that you have just entered
people that are [ __ ] tardy no people
that
i don't feel tardy okay we said though
you had to have like
an amazing reason because being that you
were
with the badge i know that being on time
that's like that goes one-on-one it
always says
today something happened oh you're at
the vf
gotcha no no no
i was uh in the neighborhood they would
say just up in the hotel you know
i've been up seven o'clock drinking
coffee on my front patio
me my ipad my dog my phone and then
[ __ ] lotion my cbd lotion all of a
sudden
all of a sudden i get phone calls about
from the netflix people i get phone
calls from a
partner of mine whose nephew died got
murdered last night
okay i had all kinds of calls coming i
just kept going and going and going
every time i'd get up another phone call
and i realized and for some reason it's
been the harder because i could have
just said stop no more i'm going to turn
a phone off
but i could have swore that just kicked
my ass
i thought the show started at 2 30. and
not until i realized
when i got your message you're running a
little late you know it's really kind of
hard to be mad at somebody
who who's playing mind games already
and so i just this guy this this is no
good to say right you know i'm a
dependable guy you know i
i live by my mother so i'm like i bet
you he's gonna have like
an amazing race i don't
have a larger lure that you're on the
show better since i've been around you
now like 10 weeks
i'm trying to poke holes in that whole
story while you're talking i'm thinking
is that true
is he saying this hey listen i'm the
last person to be late and i was like
is that right or is it am i the first
person is there sometimes
does he ghost people or you know no
that's right you know what that one
means ghost ghosting yeah uh no
no that's where i'll be the millennial
translator yes
so ghosty means where you're totally in
contact with someone and then
like overnight your casper and you just
go so like you don't talk to them you
don't return their texts anymore
you leave them on reddit
now you're talking my life
and then what happened in my head for
the door
i looked fine another guy came by
my car well i i just got to hurry up
well welcome welcome
thank you i gotta hurry up about all
those takes two more steps plenty more
beers
but the reason yeah that's also um
should you introduce yourself
i'm not good at it yeah sure so hey
everyone i'm liza monet morales i'm an
actor
a television host and a content creator
and a proud latina
more than that specifically i'm a sixth
generation angelino so
i bow down to gil uh we got stories we
can talk about
theo george as well and super pumped
because we just celebrated the drop of
his nft on friday of cha chalucha
so if you definitely want to uh you know
pick one up you can head over to
nft.chachalucha
okay i know there's people that don't
understand do you know what an nft is no
i was
like people like real close to you right
now we're starting with ghosting and
we're moving up yeah
see look it it's an amateur okay an mft
is masa for tamales but
they're so close but they're so
different so an nft
is a non-fungible token
and we're going to still break that down
further now snoop dogg when we were
talking with him he was like
yes i know snoop dogg was like nft i
think
stands more for like never forget to
pass i was like okay bet
so essentially an nft you can turn
anything into an nft
it starts as like let's say a digital
painting right
and then from there you can add to it
what they call unlockables
so you can unlock a zoom call let's say
with george or to come play
at his golf tournament you know which
benefits his foundation which is
actually one of the things that we're
doing
if you had the via shoe let's say or a
drawing of the shoe
um you could actually do that as an nft
because we know
how important that shoe is i mean gil
for the people at home that just don't
know
i i love when you do this drop how many
shoes
were there and how many came to
california 1 356 on january 9 1980 yes
he still knows the name this is what i'm
saying and so if you had like a sketch
or that or like a clipping let's say
you could actually make that as an nft
you would print it you know mint it on
the blockchain
so the blockchain is just think about in
the world right on the digital c
if you will the openc and then one
person
will have the name as the owner now this
is where it gets complicated
but here's the thing at the end of the
day a big shout out also to ferocious
18 years old from el salvador salvadoran
american
literally broke the internet on
christie's two weeks ago uh
with uh photia's sale that they did
over 750 thousand dollars that they made
on paintings
from ferocious is a teen years and it
was awesome because he combined
digital art but then for each one of
them he did one for his
13th 14th 15th and 16th year he actually
made cases for people and hand-painted
them
and then included his diary notes from
those times and so it's like
art on another level that's super cool
yeah art with the with the
with the backstory yeah all right with
the backstory mira
how you can simplify it tell them about
yours which i tried lucha how that came
to be
so mine is uh there's a guy named randy
uh
levy blind black pearl came to me
because he has a sister that's in
my foundation and they lost a
sister when they were younger to kidney
disease and then the idea of kidney
disease
was important to them and then she came
with her husband larry and helped
us when like i couldn't keep the doors
open
you know of the foundation and they
always stepped up the part of the cole's
family but you know um i didn't rely on
them but they
they helped and we created this with
this guy ali sabed
who's an incredible nft might be one
number the top yeah artist
and we did these these um uh luchadores
and yes
our own mass with background and
with uh the nft
and a hoodie and a one-of-a-kind
mask when you buy the nft and we're just
getting started and really i don't think
the latino community
is real up on it do you think yeah not
yet uh
just did his also with cyprus hill which
was awesome we launched it on clubhouse
launched yours on clubhouse we had over
16 000 people inside the latinx town
hall come through
to be there uh and to support it yeah
and so there's 50
the first round was creating 51 of ones
right now there's currently only 20 left
i got you one uh yeah i'm proud of the
one i got i'm super excited
uh but the cool thing i mean this is the
part that you're forgetting so ali
actually uh you know made them and you
can see there's the touches of the mucha
libre from our culture
but george infused each one of them with
a personality
so i really love how they all have
strengths they have weaknesses and stuff
he when we asked him he said that he was
a roman pico so do you remember what the
strengths and weaknesses are for them
he's got no weaknesses he said he
remembered
he reminded me that's what i said
uh um but they're not supposed to be him
right they're supposed to have their own
yeah i don't know i don't remember
that he didn't got it he told me
the strength is not memory that's
straight that's strange
everything rolls off his back only
because he can't remember it
you just mentioned something you told me
to ask my son i said when i see my son
later on
in the clubhouse okay i don't even know
what club aside from all that we're
gonna get gil on clubhouse
right now right now so so el romantico
with the ray romance he likes winning
hates losing his personality
his his weakness is cakes got chili
and the superpower is uh crushing hugs
power like you can crush you with a hug
and uh i couldn't hug people when i was
growing up i didn't know how
i don't know if you ever knew anybody
would know how or not to know how but
when you don't get hugged
you don't know what to do like you're
trying to what are they trying to do
taking them back into the dentist where
are you taking they're hugging you
like grab them you know so so it's
always been uh
a thing with me that that uh and listen
man
you know me and the green river killer
have the same traits
his mom used to give him a bath in his
and her robe would open
and uh gotcha man i'm really not
supposed to be
even in this studio i'll supposed to be
out there somewhere lancashire
by the old palomino club but that's
trying to make people disappear
you're saying that you weren't hugged i
mean obviously that's
hugging is such a big part of like the
latino community so at what point
do you feel like you crossed over do you
think
because i'm sure you hug my in you know
i
you know i don't know i i you know i
can't say
i would just say that i will just say
that this
business allows you to have a lot of
personal personality flaws but still be
effective at your job
yeah because it's a solitary existence
you can travel by yourself
take a road manager you got opening guy
you're supposed to work from this time
of this time you got security guys
everybody distant pick the game where
you can play by yourself
golf and stand up you could you need an
audience where you sell tickets and then
you know trying to play the guitar in
the house with
you know solito so you know it's not
it's not bad
it's not bad i mean it it's not healthy
but you know sometimes well the pandemic
definitely encouraged a lot of people to
not
you know be hugging either i'm a hunger
my dad never was you know and all i ever
wanted to do was impress my dad i wanted
to win him i wanted to be proud of him
my mom you know i was a consentido i was
number one i was out of seven kids i was
the only boy
so i had six sisters but i was i was
mamas you know i was number five in the
in the rotation so i i might as well as
if i needed more food
and and she would uh she was always
there
when i became a dad
and my kids i don't care how drunk i was
i don't care how long i had been away
uh and i don't care if they were asleep
i said i love you
every day oh i love that you did i love
them and every chance i got
i hug them and my grandkids now they're
little the little ones
they come up and they come up and they
give me that you know they're not used
to hugging them they
one of them gives me the shoulder i said
no moderate coverage come here
yeah give me uh an anaconda squeeze
that's beautiful yeah that's from
natural library give me a
second we're huggers and
everybody is in the face and if you and
if your dad wasn't how did how did you
get it
like did you know you didn't want to be
that you you learn by your mistakes you
learn by what
what the past and the past was i knew
the empty feeling i had
i didn't want my kids to have that
feeling i wanted to make sure
that they knew i was proud of them if
they [ __ ] in the toilet
i was proud of them because they made it
there yeah and so
it didn't matter i i want to know that
their dad loves them
and their dad was proud of them what
about riding in the car with your dad is
and you guys were alone anything better
than that no we didn't we didn't do he
was hard working man he worked
uh five six days a week he had a company
pickup truck
on saturdays he'd get up he'd go do the
shopping for for the family
he'd go buy instead of a can of tomato
sauce he'd buy two cases because it was
on sale
right he'd plot out get the mario's this
is on sale over here this time he had a
pantry in the garage so he could put all
the extra food in there that took up his
day
saturday by the time he came home i
better have had the grass cut or
whatever i was supposed to do
and he wouldn't tell me to do it he
would just uh maybe the grass
needs some cutting oh oh that passive
aggressiveness
oh my god that's so that's the way it
was we never
i got to go to dodge baseball games with
him
which was awesome best even though we we
parked all the way at the bottom
where the old uh naval station is now
it's a fire
something and then we'd walk all the way
up to the top [ __ ] four mile
all the way up to the top to the nose
that was great
i was with my dad it was not your
baseball it was the best i wish she'd
have been around long enough
when i had season tickets for now i know
that we ain't walking that [ __ ] no more
i'll drop you off and you can walk up if
you want but we're going to sit in the
good seats down here
so it would it was good i love that you
brought that up though about uh
doing breaking the cycle because it
wasn't done for you
because i know george um had talked
about we did an interview with him last
week about how
you know he didn't hear his grandmother
say i love you right and
i it reminded me so much of a time with
my mom too the same thing that
that whole generation of like our
grandparents they weren't raised with
anybody saying it to them
so like they didn't know any better and
i remember my mom said she was probably
in high school when she finally told my
grandmother like
and my grandma's like what do you mean
like i'm showing you right like i'm
making food for you i put you in private
school all these things
that's me telling you that i love you my
mom's like no i need to hear you say
you love me and it was interesting
because it really cracked my grandmother
and it took her some time
and it wasn't until i was born that then
they started seeing it and my
you know my grandmother would see my mom
do it and me do it to my mom
and so she started doing it and i
remember her being like
in the back and she would start reading
these books spiritual books all of a
sudden right
and she would say i love you and i would
hear her now telling like my aunts and
stuff
but it was because no one did it for her
that she didn't even know that there was
a cycle to break okay
i want to say to people that are
watching or anybody that has
you know has people around him or knows
people that
usually they're maybe a little bit older
now who would still be if you have
somebody that
that says you know that doesn't say they
love you and like
what elijah says like a cracked her
because
i know that i can i can remember one
instance when you know i was going to
therapy
and the therapist said hey you know what
did your grandmother do she watches tv
all the time which is using it as a
like a deflection to kind of hear you
but
not hear you turn the tv off and then
don't ask her you're going to turn the
tv just turn it off i go over there
turn the tv off and she goes what are
you doing what's going on and i said i
need to ask you something
and i said do you love me and
immediately she goes who who told you to
tell me that and because anne's always
talking
i said no no no i'm not i'm telling you
do you love me and she gets his face and
she turns her head and i said
i said you gotta you gotta you gotta
tell me or what what the
you know and then she says i have to
you're my grandson
but i know that if i would have made her
say
it i think it would have cracked her but
she did not have
an easy life but that's her life that's
not my life but at some point
do we just have to get over it is it
something that you let the past go
i mean i don't know i don't know eliza i
don't know if you're that easy about
my dad what i said about my dad my dad
had never said i love you
i had never told my dad i love you
night before he passes people in his
hospital people in the room
he knows he's he's dying and i told
everybody leave the room
got to talk to my dad so i went up and i
grabbed his hand
i said dad i've never said this before
but i got to tell you
i love you i love you dad
he said mijo me too
didn't say i love you just said me too
i knew he loved me i knew it was there
it would have been beautiful to hear so
he passes in the morning i'm telling my
sister the next day i said you know what
my dad never said he loved me i just
wish i had heard him say it one time
and she said you know he loved you i
said yeah i know he did but i just
one of those things she came back about
half hour later she found my dad
they were going through my dad's stuff
and they found a metal can because my
dad
he's a mexican he had his little file
box in his
in his closet ten thousand dollars cash
d to the house all the insurance papers
funeral arrangements
everything's there all wrapped up
you think you're dead didn't love you in
a newspaper article
about me when i was trying to raise
some help to start an orphanage in
vietnam
the most important papers of his life
you were part of he loved you
and it was you know yeah wait a minute
can we toast to your dad it's been like
three minutes and i've almost cried
you're the one crying i'm wiping my eyes
and i'm taking the beer away
you know what and that's why that's why
the first time that i talked to gil
thought he didn't know me i didn't know
him and
when i hung up i was like and this is
rare like i feel like i've known this
guy my whole life
and i mean that's it's not vulnerable
you're not vulnerable
you're just you're somebody's real like
very few people that are real this dude
is a real
real person oh yeah
that's what made him good at what he did
and that's why he remembers things that
are important
and that's why you know that's why i'm
overweight
you're actually under
you're 25 foreign under because then you
scale that there's a new uh
you know i used to go to the doctor we
used to go to the doctor and have some
[ __ ] in the 50s and they'd go the doctor
would go
how tall are you sir uh 511 and how
about
how much do you weigh 210 oh well from
here
this yeah you 511 you're supposed to
weigh 130. what the [ __ ] is it
the [ __ ] when everybody worked that
gimbals they [ __ ] 19 [ __ ] 20.
it doesn't that doesn't that doesn't
work but no you know
that's i mean
it would be great to hear but you know
but also i didn't know you're trying to
start orphanage in vietnam
and and like that stuff is
what remains to the soul you know that's
in your soul
and you know that somebody you know i
was watching this thing on kennedy and
that gun that jack ruby used
we made it you know there's only like
three owners and the second owner
had it in a purple crown royal bag it
said in the article
there you go that's the real [ __ ] yeah
hey
i bought jack ruby's gun i put it in
this purple [ __ ] bag
nobody touch it it fits in a chrome
royal bag and it's just so
it's all the [ __ ] that you know my
grandma had everything in the oven i
said what birthday baby
and uh it was it was a this guy one time
came to me and he gave me a green
and a blue like that blue and a purple
crumb oil bag after the show
and like like like girl i was like wait
a minute this is for me
[Laughter]
but but uh but yeah and he's a good man
good father about the kids
and and all of and all that and
he's one of the few latinos that
wherever he says he is he is like me
i'm not you know not even [ __ ]
three-quarters of the time i'll say
oh no i'm over here i'm not there but he
he's been married for over 50 years and
he is
he is where he says he is pearl's
awesome she was doing okay she was
she was at home right now while i was on
the phone doing this hey hey are you on
the phone right now yes i got an earbud
did you she's great she went out the
other day to buy uh
i had uh i just the time that i was off
i was laid up a little bit
i hurt my back at home and so i'm just
laying and she's you know what
the washer went out i said god just go
just go buy a new one you know i i don't
care you know
we either got to wait for somebody to
come pick it up they're going to tell us
too expensive
yeah just go if you want one go find it
so she went out
and she doesn't do stuff like that i'm
the one that goes out and buys the
appliance everything
so she goes out she comes back and she's
all proud
you know hey i bought this it's how much
it costs and
i said me down here i said hey that's
good that's a good price
and then she's calling she's called me
up and she's hey
you know what i found out why it was
such a good price they forgot to put the
pedestal on there they didn't charge me
for the pedestal we need to get the best
one
and i said okay dear go ahead you know i
was in a hurry when i left
i left i got my i got my driver's
license and my id that's about it i left
no money
no what's the secret is to ask you
before you have to walk out the door if
you can buy something
okay i'm taking notes no i think uh
well first of all you know we used to
buy [ __ ] it never fit like you know
the size of the refrigerator in my
grandma's house was a size of not a big
refrigerator
but you know my grandmother went to go
by the refrigerator and then it had you
could make
get ice and water i'm like grandma
grandma it that's not going to fit combo
is not going to fizz that refrigerator
it's not going to fit well i already
bought it so we'll make it fair you
can't make it fit because it isn't
going there it doesn't fit so it's in
the patio
with a cord from the garage through a
window out to the patio
what are we gonna do with this uh this
whole this this place with a friend
like uh you could do your homework in
there the [ __ ] place for the
refrigerator
and still with the screen lifted up and
uh you know nobody's gonna get in
you know so so why are you looking at
your watch are we are we behind who's
oh no man i get uh i get alerts from our
podcast you know what i stopped i
stopped wearing a watch in here
to your show because i found myself
looking at my watch and
and one time you said we're gonna be
done in a bit and and that
i just at a half it just one of those i
watches so
yeah that's that's what i got to see
that's how i got an old
400 hours or you are back with the
[ __ ] regular civilization
i'm back with a civilization right
unless i'm talking to the guys unless
the [ __ ] thing i still do military
tactics
i already did that and you'll know that
i already know i already know
wait so one thing that you actually
talked about which i think is so awesome
you know speaking about pearl and one
thing that's millennials about him being
on the thing
we've gotta have his heart
oh my god oh my god that's an mft right
that's an nft
mina that is that is my grandson
i said hey hey come here come here come
here come here this is a guy that was
gone nuts over the fact that i had that
i was on here with be real
oh i love it and he's uh just turned 22
and i said look it you think you're bad
look at this [ __ ]
i don't need a six-pack i got a got a
barrel right here brother
but that's my picture uh
and he couldn't believe it he was upside
down it is it is
i love it it looks good i was gonna ask
you about family because that's one
thing that
we talk about so much as millennials
especially relationships because
dating is like non-existent these days
uh for us um
i love how you have stayed true and
loyal and always talk about the power of
family
with pearl so i would love to know like
what are the words of wisdom that you
would give to people
because your job man she's a full-on
classy chinguana
find somebody find somebody like pearl
because she's okay pearl we need you to
make
she's the one she's the one that has
kept it together not me
trust me she's the glue that's kept
everything together she's had to
tolerate my
shortcomings and everything else that
has gone on with the job without the job
and everything that i've done and had it
not been for her and her desire to keep
everything together
we wouldn't be together she's the glue
so you got to find somebody like her
it's pretty amazing it is it's amazing
yeah because not only that
he wasn't resistant to
wanting to have her in his life like
when he came back from vietnam
you wanted to get her back and then dump
her i wanted a dumper so
that of course because you wanted that's
a latino
if i could survive vietnam i could
survive pearl i'm gonna bring her into
my life
and then i'm gonna get her pearl harbor
like yesterday's garbage and that way
she could feel when he felt
this old school and it didn't last she
won
i got two out of ten i got two out of
three eight
i got he had a three so but her family
too like she was
the family like because she had an open
heart her dad loved me her mom hated me
oh my god her mother hated me and i
could say it now i don't care
her mom you ask anybody in her family
including my wife sheldon my
her mother hated me i before i went to
vietnam
i went down her mom and dad's house and
we were in love and you know
and i'm sitting there i'm only 18 years
old
and i went to her mom and dad i wanted
to have a meeting with him and i said
hey look
when i get out of the service i'm just
asking your permission
i'd like to get married to your daughter
because that's the way i guess it was in
the old days you asked for permission
so as soon as i said that her mother got
up and walked out of the house oh my god
oh my god you're like she's just going
to get the ring she's she's very excited
about that so
she walked out my wife my girlfriend
then started crying and said see dad
this is why we don't get along
so he went next door neighbor the next
door neighbor was my wife's cousin
who had been raised like a sister
because
her mother passed away and my
mother-in-law raised her
so they went over there and then he
comes back and he says okay i talked to
my wife i want you to come back tomorrow
you say everything you have to say on
your mind if she gets someone walks out
on you again tomorrow
don't wait till you come back from
vietnam take my daughter to vegas go get
married
wow wow and i said that's not what i
want
you know that that isn't what i really
want so she came back next day and we
talked
and she said well we just don't get
along when she's with you yeah and she
gave me all the reasons i said
look at it this way i'm going to vietnam
maybe i'll get killed you won't have to
worry about it oh my god you said that
yeah i said maybe i'll die and it'll all
it's just another world
she started crying she was well that's
not what i want for you but still it's
not
i said okay well we've got so much time
why don't we just wait
and so that's what we did then my wife
gabrona she went ahead and sent me the
dear john
oh she sent me the dear john when i was
in vietnam
oh and so it broke my corazon oh my god
oh i know i keep my so she did that
so natural progression when i get out
okay come on now i want you back
yeah and i want to dump you like you did
did me
it didn't work out you know the the
first day i saw her
i went to her cousin's house to visit uh
visit the kids because the cousins were
we were friends i went over there
knowing that it's close to the house
yeah so i went over there and some girl
some old friend of ours
let's just say she was a friendly young
lady oh my and so
we she called up over there in the
country she was hey why don't you come
down the house and you know say hi
just for old times and i said sounds
good to me they trap you i don't even
know where you live she says
well pearl will be going over right now
she she'll show you how she'll give me
the address
well here comes bro walking in the house
pretty soon and i said hey i just got
done talking about so-and-so and you
know
she said you give me the dress i'll be
right back she went back she came back
she got
she opened the door she got in my car
and said okay let's go and she scooted
on over
and i said wait a minute what did you
tell your mother i mean her mother just
right there and wow i said would you
tell your mother she said i told my mom
i was going out on a date with you
so that's what started it and by
september i had her eating out of my
hand i got out in june by september i
had her eating out of the pool or so you
think so you think
you think you won and so i i've told my
i've told my parents my
my mom especially remember i'm the
consentido yeah my mom didn't like her
i was gonna say latina mom she dumped
her
made him suffer and then my mom saw her
at a wedding with the other dude
oh no so she's over here having a good
time my son's over there oh man so my
mom really did so i went up to my mom
and i said okay let me tell you
something right now mom
that's going to be my wife tell my
sisters
just so everybody knows don't be talking
smack you know that's that's going to be
my wife
and december day after christmas we got
married
wow so what year
hey you can see now what day was it
probably december 26th it
after christmas and and i got married
and i told my wife recently you know you
stopped to realize yours is a homicide
cop if i'd have whacked you there not
already been out of joy
no i'm a free man right now but you know
he he did everything you know he did you
did everything
when you came back more when you
realized
how dangerous that was for on the
minute-by-minute basis in vietnam that
well how people were not welcoming i
unfortunately lost an uncle there and
then i know
for my uncle that did come back he
didn't come back the same and
i remember just being really little and
always having to be told like you can't
go into that room um
we have my aunt would have to go in and
flick on the lights and do this whole
thing because of the ptsd and
you have to wait for him to come out and
be like i don't understand and they're
like you'll understand when you're older
but
you know there was all these special
precautions and it pains me to this day
when i just see how poorly our vets were
treated then and sometimes even now
which is why
i do so much to help the vets as well
well i i thank you on that when i came
back it was tough
you know and you never talked about
vietnam because we were all these
baby killers
so they finally got over that you know
and when we came back from
uh operation desert storm they had a
parade in hollywood and my wife prior to
them had gone down
on the block of my house with my kids
and tied a yellow ribbon
we're on every tree and so i said
when they come back well i'm going to be
there waving the flag
treat them like they didn't treat us you
know let's go over there so we went over
there
we watch them then here comes a group of
uh guys in the parade
and he was older guys you look at him
and
there's a group of vietnam veterans that
were crying their hearts out
and people were standing giving them
probation as they went down
amongst all these young troops who were
coming back
because they were finally getting
recognition and then the paper said the
next day you know
any vietnam veteran was welcome to jump
in there and be in the and my wife said
oh you could have gone i said no i
didn't need it they needed it yeah
i didn't i'm okay i've got it all
together
today in law enforcement 38 years i
spent
and and i loved it i wouldn't trade it
it was a great job it was very rewarding
for me
nobody had as much fun as i did on the
job and yet
i feel the same way i did when i came
back from vietnam can't talk about it
because
right now police work law enforcement
not a popular subject right
and some guys have screwed up they've
messed up they've made it bad you make
it bad for one you make it bad for me
everybody and so it's it's a tough road
to hold right now so i was in the reno
airport
january 17th oh look at me that george
dropping
facts and i saw a war world war
ii veteran god was yeah and he was by
himself
and i walked up and i introduced myself
and he was waiting for his wife and i
took them and i bought them
uh dinner and lunch and
breakfast for the next day that's
amazing and i thanked him for his
service and
and i went over there and i said can i
take a picture he was oh he was happy
world war ii wow and i saw the hat and i
said wait a minute i got to go i said
hey man
you didn't just get that on amazon right
like you're like actually yeah right
i got a connection and i almost gave him
that [ __ ] watch it but then
i said i'm gonna give him this watch and
i said no maybe if you know
if did you go to korea too no okay
but i mean you know um yeah they are
under
ah man that was that place right there
in high school and the valleys have
another valley
and then in uh uh off the 405
that you know that we don't look after
them teachers either anybody that
you know defends this country and even
latinos veterans were getting deported
so i was like in the
deathless thing i said hey man if you
can die for this country you can live in
this country
exactly uh and then netflix cut that out
but but i mean it's all of that that
makes
you know our stories important and then
we always have to hear from
from somebody else that doesn't look
like us
and i think one of the things about
that's great about having dylan
on the podcast is i don't have any depth
at all so there's a depth right here
there's
like two little two little containers
one like this is that one
but but i mean it's uh it's it's great
how do we get them on clubhouse
now we transition we can start our room
we have to get your account set up give
us your phone
what you do yeah are you familiar with
clubhouse i know we got into it a little
bit
no i don't know it's run by the spear
member i know
no yes
yeah so clubhouse is an audio social app
and
it's awesome it started last march i
actually joined last august and i'm the
as i mentioned before i'm the founder of
the latinx town hall on there
but what's really cool is you can
connect with people from around the
world
you don't have to worry about looking
cute or whatever because it's just your
voice
and i think that and george i would love
to hear your opinion but i think what i
found to be really cool about it is as
latinos we come with the [ __ ] meter
right like we can tell when people are
trying to [ __ ] already i'm sure you
even more as a detective right
but what's awesome is people might be
able to fake it sometimes when
you know they're talking or they're
going to act and what have you
there's something about when it's just
the voice that you can't fake it that
energy
really carries through and so very
quickly you've been able to see people
that have
presence there and that people want to
come and listen to versus those that
you're like ah you're being a cloud
chaser that's another word
so a cloud chaser someone that's just
chasing the fame
but doesn't really have substance they
just want to be famous not for anything
but just to be famous right
and so will be users if you will or
steam climbers i believe is a word they
used to use back in the day
um and so would you hurt some climber no
yeah
so i what i like about it i remember
back in the day
yeah like did you have anybody i mean
because look at you girl like you were
the youngest yeah the post
but like you were the youngest latino
right when you were i'm in the force to
get the ranks that you did like
did you have people that were you know
doing it for show they would you know
get those brownie points i guess brown
knows her maybe you know
and everything but we didn't uh on the
job
for the most part we didn't see color
you know everybody was a cop
nobody had any because i was mexican i
was first latino above the rank of
sergeant to go to homicide bureau right
but that wasn't a long-term goal i just
realized hey
there's never been anybody up here you
know there's half sort of been somebody
smarter
but also but also in business
in police work in whatever i'm sure
people have been victims of this
where somebody would tell you their idea
and then they take it and get credit for
it
and then they forget that they heard it
from somebody
and then they're like hey man that was
my idea no it wasn't i talked to you
about it like they could convince
themselves that
that wasn't the per they took this i
mean doesn't that happen in comedy all
the time
absolutely oh yeah like on the daily
people doing their jokes
yeah well it's not it's not people steal
the jokes it's like you know
nobody really wants to do the work so
they they're looking for their cloud
chasers
and then when something doesn't go their
way
now you're back to the place where you
got to do your work
i mean i've been out to portland tacoma
you were just in nashville salt lake and
nashville in this last month
about 60. and i'm trying to see if i
look if i love it as much as i
think i do if if what i want to say is
important enough to continue to maybe do
one more special because you know i
[ __ ] want to enjoy my life too but
that's not that's not easy and you're
not phoning it in
i'm working so i missed a show last
tuesday because i didn't feel good or
traveling and i didn't sleep well during
it
and during the day when i should have
and i said hey i'm not going to tell
these guys i'm not going to do the show
i don't feel well enough you know and
then the next i did two and two
and you come back and you're tired i'm
60.
so there's not another george lopez that
you can just pass the
patonya and dodgers the guy where is
that number 15 you're like oh
wow the same number that's the same dude
there's not that
voice out there and unfortunately
there's not anybody really to carry the
mantle i don't think it's in comedy so
yeah i'll be i'll be the man that's
right i'll be that mental code
so so you know so so all of that but
it's
never easy to do the work and i think
that's one of the things you say
and in the clubhouse that we did for the
nfts you can see
and i mean you can hear people's
emotions when they talk about what
either the first show meant to them or
whether what i meant to them or the
things that i said meant to them
and first of all it's good for me
because i don't have to think that i'm
like the lone ranger
but it's good for them because they get
to hear my voice say
thank you i appreciate that incredible
congratulations
where they wouldn't have access to
somebody but also
mental health every issue in the world
is covered on clubhouse and you don't
have to participate
you can listen if you want to
participate at some point you can but
you can get
books of knowledge simply by
by listening and i think that's if
there's anything
great about this it's not about how fat
your asses not about what you're wearing
it's not about how you dance
it's about how you sound and your your
vulnerability your real ability and your
ability or your profession
and your advice that people would be
able to smell [ __ ]
a mile away literally but also in
georgia and you can talk about this too
what i thought was awesome is we had so
many people
that even stayed up in europe it was 3
a.m 4 a.m 5 a.m
um you know that speak spanish
specifically that wanted to be there to
wanted to hear
and not only even listen to you but also
share with each other of like
i remember you know this watching this
show or um you know the kidney story
that we heard about how someone was able
to find a kidney because of the
foundation
uh which chachalucha they were really
most uh
lured to right so you hear these
experiences from people and i always say
it's the one investment that we can't
get back is time so when someone chooses
to spend time like those who are
listening to the podcast today and if
you haven't subscribed you should
and if you haven't left a review what
are you waiting for you should right
like yes
and to choose to be there you know we
were only going to be in on for an
hour uh thank you so much again george
he ended up extending we were there like
two and a half hours
but people were like hanging on for
baited breath we had over 16 000 people
come through
and they just were so excited to be
united and i think through the pandemic
that sense of connection and being able
to have human
touch even though you weren't physically
there but could hear someone
really got through to people and it
actually helped them
carry these last couple of months and i
think that that's why that app really
has popped and now we're seeing it
jump on on others like facebook is doing
their version spotify is doing theirs
twitter is doing theirs but
the community that's built on clubhouse
is i think what separates it from
it's really in listening to you talk you
talk about
two things that are extremely important
and number one you can tell when
somebody's blowing smoke or listening
okay two gate greatest functions two
most important functions
of a decent homicide comp is the ability
to understand
why people are doing what they're doing
why they did what they did
so when people are talking you have to
understand where they're coming from or
why
you don't have to condone it you just
have to understand it
and number two the second most important
thing
is the ability to listen not to yourself
but listen to what others are saying
and take it all in before you have a
response make it a decent responsibility
the art of listening that's the toughest
one to conquer for most people you know
because
their egos their spontaneity they want
to yeah well i know this and you're
already thinking of a response no
you have to have that ability to listen
so it's intrigued me just to hear what
you guys have said so far
yeah and i think something that you said
it's important as an actor i find myself
and even as a host like you know really
being conscious and checking in and i
find it that it becomes so useful on
clubhouse because to your point
we can see when someone isn't there to
listen or to contribute that they just
want to like
amplify or glorify themselves because
they'll jump in to cut someone off
and i'm like if i'm moderating a room
excuse me hold on no we have one mic we
one person is still speaking like
there's a cue and luckily we didn't have
too much of that
but you can notice it versus someone
that genuinely which is what i really
commit myself to doing if i'm going to
be present i want to be fully present
so that i can hear what you have to say
not here with
oh here's what i'm going to say to
respond but to hear and actually let it
impact me and then go from there right
and i think when you have that you have
these transformations and we've seen
that happen
so so we're going to open a room right
here running for president
uh i think she should okay so you have
to put in your number so that i can send
you an invite i reserved your name
but don't say it on that one
it so is it is it uh was being a
detective
something that you could turn off even
though you retired
like no no no no because i think you
know
we know what they say uh and not not
this doesn't apply to you but you know
how they say
sometimes like the baseball managers a
lot of the guys that weren't very good
make great like they used to say hey
those that can't teach which
is a horrible [ __ ] proverb wherever
the [ __ ] that came from
but but when a lot of the managers that
were successful weren't very good as
players because they watched everything
but they knew
moves and they could see they're
watching the whole game not a guy that
was
you know playing he's only worried about
his position where to throw the ball
but i would find it interesting
well not interesting i know for a fact
that
even though you're retired that when you
see something that your mind doesn't go
to it oh it does the juices start to
flow
i really got excited over this uh the
golden state killer
yeah you know that right right that
that's a heavy case that's good
and i'm telling a friend of mine who
used to be a profiler with the fbi back
in quantico virginia
and i'm saying bill god i wish i want to
work the case and i want to get on it
because
there's so much there and he says that's
just because it's never left you you
know you're
still you still have it you've got it
you can teach it you can dig you can do
anything you want it's still in you so i
still
when i see cases but where did you see
that what did you see
but uh because that guy was dormant
right so so there's not certainly
dna and then dna comes and
the whole case was the the ability the
art
hopefully we'll certainly have the
scientific side of it when they made the
dna
but then the ability would be the
challenges get them to talk
like that's that's the
you know study everything know the ins
and outs and then get him to talk
without upsetting them without doing it
without him
saying the magic words i want an
attorney right away
and then you know when they caught him
he went in there all of a sudden you
know the guy's at home cooking chicken
and he's like hey i gotta turn my oven
off
and then when he gets to court i i
believe he's playing like he's not well
yeah he's in a wheelchair yeah he's in a
wheelchair so
you know he was in the wheelchair so
that he i don't know what kind of
sympathy you think you're going to
derive from
that but he you know he never spoke he
never
talked he never even sister mary
clarence
la perla even she said oh look at him
now yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's awesome even
uh oh sure even she said like yeah
there's no way [ __ ]
dragging his feet right oh yeah it says
how does it spin the hook you see it all
the time you see with like the cosby
defense and the yc defense and it's like
as soon as
as soon as you're showing up somewhere
in public or they're like oh look that
was major controversy you say cosby
and i and i listen to lies that say no
don't even say major controversy in my
house
you know because my wife says oh he's
guilty he's dirty he did all this [ __ ]
now he's getting out feeding that
he said wait a minute dear you know that
people
you're you're feeling with your heart
wait a minute i got a message from bill
cosby howard
hang on now i don't understand that
you're listening with your heart
even he and he agreed with you hang on
honey you don't understand
that people are thinking they're
listening with the heart
they don't know a deal was already made
who made why did they make that deal i'm
not in support you know
not in support of anything either way
i'm in support of
the law the law that's all it is it's
the law
the law says if you make a deal this guy
was a deputy
he was with the district attorney's
office he made a deal hey
you go ahead and make this statement go
ahead and
go on a record i'm saying it and we
won't use it against you
so it won't be brought up and why do
they want that yo why do they want that
i don't know if they wanted to solve
other other cases or just go ahead and
clear them up
because i don't know what was in his
mind or what they were thinking at the
time that they did it
the bottom line was whether it was right
or was wrong they did it
it's done so now a district attorney so
now
let's say this happened in east l.a and
all of a sudden he gets
he gets in trouble in pacoima so the d.a
over there that handles that said
hey we're going to use this [ __ ] against
you and they did it
they used it against them and the state
supreme court over there said hey wait a
minute
a deal's a deal you said no you wouldn't
just because you're in a different
district doesn't mean you can
so this deal therefore everything that
came after that that's
fruit of the poison tree you can't use
it
so it's thrown out and it throws out any
future cases because
he talks about some of the other ladies
in there that can't be used against him
so i'm not saying he's innocent i'm not
saying he's guilty i don't care the law
is the law
and my my wife she's a latina i mean
puerto madre i don't care
right you know he he's dirty so i well
take that to the grave with your dear
people so people have that like women of
course
up in arms and but but a deal is a deal
the law is the law
and why did he do the three years if he
had a deal
because he was on appeal right he was on
appeal they convicted him
but it's okay appeals process to get up
to the supreme court and say hey wait a
minute
you can't use it we're vacating the
entire thing
that's the problem if you have one
boo-boo everything gets thrown out and
if we talk about the appeal process even
if we go back to your case right with
the night stalker
he actually was technically supposed to
go to the gas chamber
but by the time he would have gone
through the long lengthy california
appeals process
he wouldn't have even been it would have
been 70 before he would have gotten in
there
you know and so but that was like on
paper
right i remember we studied this in in
law school and so they were like oh he
was gonna go to that and i'm like yeah
by the time that he was gonna be done
he would be out having children you know
like it just wasn't gonna happen and to
your point
when you can play the law to your side
it can win and so i agree with you that
the law is the law but i also think that
the law isn't always right
you know i don't know if the law is
always right i don't make the laws all i
do
exactly so it it is what it is if
i made a mistake like that against a
murder suspect i had
i don't care how heinous he was if i'd
have done that with richard
right my bad right that's what i'm
saying yeah that's that's
that's the law yeah if you guys would
have took him in there and go listen man
just
you know tell us what happened and you
won't be prosecuted
right uh and just tell us who you know
one or two
or all whatever whatever and he's like
okay this is what
what happened you can use it potentially
to you know capture other guys like me
right this is what happened yeah and
even today i heard that when somebody
when you give somebody a
lie detector test you're almost telling
them i don't have anything on you
oh yeah it's just a tool that's all yeah
trying to get on break they don't know
what they're doing
but it's not a good because you're just
kind of telling them i don't have
anything that's your bluff
i don't have anything on you but yeah
if you take this test i can get my
supervisors off my ass
right because they're forceful we just
want to get rid of i want to get rid of
you i don't believe you did it yeah
but i just want to get rid of you let's
try to clear your name that that's
that's the
point so his account has officially been
set up so he's following you so
definitely
and what is he real it's his name just
his name i put he kept it simple
oh no get fonzie yeah
and richard in in richard's case richard
at first said
i want an attorney i said okay all bets
are off so we get up we start walking
out
and he said wait a minute what's going
to happen next well hey wait a minute
you don't want to talk to us you want to
well i have questions well okay if you
have questions go ahead
now knowing he's already asked for an
attorney
yeah anything he says can it will be
used against him
yeah but since he's asked for an
attorney we can't use it
unless he would have taken the stand
then we could use it in rebuttal oh
right we can't use it in the case in
chief
right i'm not going to mention his name
but i think the judge sitting on the
bench that day was peter smith
and he said no names though no names he
says
it was the biggest violation of miranda
that he had ever seen
and here's his year sitting on the bench
and i would love to have the ability to
tell them today
your bench was an outhouse because
that's you know i know that that's basic
criminal law
we didn't use any of his information in
the case in chief right but if he had
taken a stand
then you could have then we could have
slammed him with it and right didn't not
one piece of evidence out of
all the time we talked did we ever use
now speaking about evidence that you
didn't use and i
i want to go there just because it just
it's very personal to me as well as like
the fact that you chose to keep the kids
out of it
right i always think of the six year
olds who with her coloring book and
hearing you tell the story and
it resonates um because i went through
something very similar at that age
and uh i always think like wow
it's so great that like you though
thought of because the law doesn't
always think of the kids
and with everybody on the team of being
like all right i think we have enough
on the adult side that we don't
necessarily have to get into what
happened with the children
right but is there ever was there ever
anything there that was left unsettled
or unresolved for closure that the
family still
wanted more no no the family was pretty
much
satisfied with our decision because we
were going
with 14 counts of murder against him
right and
what more could we give him with and was
it worth putting families together
we didn't need it and no need to put him
through the trauma so we didn't
uh probably i believe one of the best
decisions we've made on the case and
and deputy d.a phil halpen it was his
his decision he said what do you think
we we concurred with him uh we're so
happy and
i'm so glad that uh the little
six-year-old and i are very dear friends
today i was gonna ask do you still talk
to her
i never i never talked to her uh once it
happened
yeah when i retired uh
one of the local stations uh channel two
did a four and a half minute piece on me
on a lieutenant retiring they it was
unheard of you know but they did it
and i was going camping meeting my
family
and on the way over there i got a phone
call that some lady wanted to talk to me
and i talked to her and it was her
mother and
uh it was a very emotional call yeah
you're gonna get me crying
i said i i i never wanted to talk about
any of the kids i never want to follow
up on them
because i have a soft spot in my heart
for kids and i didn't want my heart to
be broken because they had gone
you know psychological problems in the
end and she says oh no it's just the
opposite every time you'd come on tv
because i used to do stand-ups for my
murder scenes
every time he came on tv everybody had
run to the tv it was almost like uncle
gills on tv you're part of the family i
can't thank you enough that we treated
my daughter
and i said i was afraid to ask and she
says oh no she's married had a set of
twins
both her and her husband and physical
therapist uh down the area they live in
and it's a beautiful beautiful thing we
just want to say thank you
so that was it when they did the
documentary i told them right up front
i will not help you get in touch with
any of the surviving family members for
sure
uh so i can't do that
well they then called me up and they
said we we reached out to her
we found her and she would like talk to
you
and so i called oh my god i have goose
bumps it was that's me for the fifth
time this time yes
it was emotional she said she was now i
think
41 42 years old she says i've been
wanting to talk to you for years but
i didn't know what to say i was a
six-year-old kid the last time i saw you
and
you know things were different what do i
say what are you saying and
so we both ended up with lumps in our
throat by the time we finished that
conversation
and i i told her i said don't do this
documentary because
you think it's good for me or for
television or anything else
you think about you you know it's your
decision so they called me back a while
later and they said
she's agreed to do it if he'll show up
on set
and so we showed up on set i showed up
on set and there was hugs and there were
tears
and we've maintained our friendship her
only flaw in life
is she's a san diego padres fan
it's okay you're so funny well next time
you speak to a fellow
thriver tell her that this sir thriver
sees her believes her and appreciates
her
oh thank you is that what people say
thank you for that
i just as a survivor just immense so i
don't just call it being a survivor
because i think we thrive out of this
out of the result
out of the result of this when you say
you're a survivor surf driver
thriver surf driver i i got
i was contacted by a girl that said
thank me for not uh giving up on the
kids yeah
because i was molested at age six and
went through age 12.
and when i finally told my family they
didn't believe me and they said i was
full of the demon
i was lying and she told me the story
and i contacted
my people over at netflix and i said hey
we
got this i just got this you know we got
to do something we can't just leave her
out there like this yeah
they said you're riding the horse you
run with it whatever she needs
will support you and so i got back in
touch with her she had already been
through
psychiatric treatment psychological
counseling she'd gone to college
she was now working as a teacher
at uh and counseling for inmates are
about to be released from texas state
penal system
wow and she was doing good had six
children was married
and her molester was her uncle richard
ramirez the night stalker
oh [ __ ] i had a feeling you were going
to go there that's that's where it was
in family didn't believe him
and her dad who was still alive
richard's brother
watched the program with her that night
and he finally apologized to her said i
now understand
you know it's been wrong and and so
there's a lot more to the family
dynamics
yeah uh than i i want to talk about
there but
she did she's a brilliant lady so such a
good lady
oh girl that just warms my heart it's so
funny you said that this morning uh
there's a show actually in clubhouse
which we can get on in a bit um that
they did it was ted you know they do the
ted talks
and so it's their first show that they
did and it was called it was all about
holding gratitude like what's a big
moment
and a little moment you want to hold
gratitude for it and so the little
moment was i wanted to appreciate and
thank everyone that actually came
through for george's drop on friday to
show up
and my big moment funny enough that you
just said that was so as i mentioned i'm
a sore thriver i
was sexually molested by four different
family members including one of my
uncles
every day from the time that i was six
to the time i was eight and so
watching watching this case and watching
everything that you did and what have
you really meant a lot to me because
um and what i gave thanks for this
morning was that my mom believed me
uh when i i wasn't able to talk about
that then
i you know really listened to my
molesters and you know as you know they
romeo you and they play mind games with
you and
they threatened me that they would hurt
my willita if i said something and they
would hurt my mom and
my parents had just gotten divorced and
unfortunately my stepmother also tried
killing me
during this time when i was six and um
yeah so
pretty heavy we can bring some more here
so
yeah so she unfortunately tried killing
me because i reminded her
of the fact that there was a
relationship with um someone other than
her prior to my dad and her getting
together
and i remember acting very instinctively
taking what i could she tried poisoning
me um and having that with me and having
it in my pocket
long story short i came with the
evidence if you will
my little legal mind i'm with my mom
once my dad had taken me home because i
would not stay at their place anymore
and they ended up going to court my dad
did lose custody
unfortunately my dad did stay married um
to her so that was like a whole thing
for me that i had to get over
so go from there to then be molested by
these different family members
i really just was at a point where in
life
i didn't understand and i thought if
everyone that's supposed to be family
and be close to me
is trying to hurt me i don't even know
why i'm here
and it's really sad like i can honestly
say i was six years old the first time i
thought of taking my life
and not understanding not knowing who i
could talk to because i was scared
that if i said something to my mom or my
grandmother that they would hurt them
right and so i was taking the world
on my shoulders and while i wasn't able
to speak about the molestation part i
did
obviously come forward with what had
happened with my stepmother trying to
kill me
and my mom believed me and took action
and they went to court and what have you
and so what i gave gratitude for this
morning i said when a kid comes to you
and tells you something believe them
because you don't even know what it
means for them to have to even come to
you
to say this happened and go from there
because it really can destroy people's
lives i've seen friends of mine whose
parents didn't believe them
versus really unite and help others
thrive which i'm so blessed because
you know i did the therapy i did the
journey and i'm very blessed to be here
uh and alive and happy but when i see
another survivor that's why it's
important for me to always acknowledge
so do we say that do we say
that partially the reason they
don't want to believe it is what it will
do to their dynamics
we don't want to blow everything up
right so no no
what did you do what were you wearing
where where
you're making it to the strong lady that
she is rosie juarez
rosie told me the story and all she
wanted was she wanted to get
her story out she didn't need help
so we did the uh tamara hall show
and her tamara hall i don't know yeah
tamara yeah
so we went on her show and they they did
it
and they taped it but just before the
ending of the taping my internet
connection
everybody in the city went out yeah the
the internet went out for the whole
the whole city where i live and so i
didn't get to hear the end of
it so the people from netflix called me
and said okay we listened to the end of
it
things sounded like they went well you
just missed a little portion they said
goodbye
everything will be good we saw you you
were great thank you very much
so i called up rosie and i said rosie
how did he go i didn't hear the end of
it and rosie was pissed and she said you
know gil
we talked about what they were going to
talk about to begin with all they really
wanted
when they asked me was the inside story
you know about my uncle and about this
about that
says they didn't ask what they were
supposed to ask they didn't do this
and so i said i'll call you right back
so i called back
the the people from the tamara hall show
and i said hey this is wrong this is not
what you said
i didn't hear it it's not okay she's not
happy we got to do something
to fix this yeah and so they did
they went ahead and they cut out her
interview
good and they redid the whole thing i'm
sorry so when it came out
and that's all she wanted to do was get
the point across
listen to your kids be heard yeah just
listen to them
and kids don't be afraid to come forward
and tell them
that was her whole message that's all
she wanted out and isn't it
interesting that i had the same thing
like there's a commonality
exactly it it doesn't happen and
especially in the latinx community like
there's the penna right and there's the
shame and so everybody wants to sweep it
under the rug when i did finally come
forward to say to my family i was in
college and
george knows i was the first in my
family to go to college and i went to
school back east and i remember coming
home
and the only reason that i was able to
have the strength if you will
is i had repressed everything but i used
to walk home every day with a rock in my
hand because i was
so scared and i had told george this in
my household
richard ramirez was the kukui right and
so my mom would always tell me and this
is after
long after he already had been caught
but she's like you have to make sure you
come home like you never know there
could be another night stalker like
what's happening so i would always be
walking with the rock in her hand and
she thought it was because of what she
was telling me little did she know it
was because i had sir thrived this
experience that i had gone through
but when i then went to school you know
i was like okay i was very prude with my
relationships in high school and stuff
because i just didn't feel comfortable
going somewhere where i had already been
violated
but i remember getting in college and
there was a psych 101 class and they did
this repressive memory exercise
and in the middle of the hallway all of
a sudden like i just remember sitting
down and we're doing it and i'm like oh
this will be so good let's see what
comes up
and boom shakalaka for the win but not
really
um i could remember everything i could
smell
um my uncle's like the beer that he
would drink i could feel his hand
everything came to life it was like the
floodgates had opened i didn't even make
it to the door i started vomiting
and i was like shaking i'm like oh my
god and i called my mom and again
in an instant she was at work and i
called her and i was like hey i need to
talk to you
like right now and she's like okay okay
and i told her and again to her credit
believed me and i was supposed to go to
spring break the next week she's like
we're canceling that you need to fly
home
we're gonna get through this and so we
did little by little i ended up finding
out and
i'm sure rosie found out too when it
happens to one it happens to many so i
found out that it opened up more of my
cousins as well
and when i came forward the family to
your point george
discredited us my aunt spit on me she
called me a [ __ ]
and she told me she's like so that's
what you went to a big fancy school for
is to learn how to like destroy a family
like why didn't you just keep it to
yourself like why did you have to bring
it up
and i'm like because you have kids and
you can stop it
if he did it to me i know that he's your
brother but this is one of the four
he's probably doing it to your kids and
when they get older
they're going to hold you accountable
for not stopping it no no
i don't know what you're talking about
he would never do it you're making
things up
statue of limitations had already passed
so again the law
not always on our side sure enough what
happens my cousin gets older
she also came forward and her and her
daughter now don't speak because
to the exact thing that i said she
didn't believe her when she came forward
and she's like oh eliza must be telling
you to say something
she's like what do you mean i was four
like i literally didn't tell me anything
we don't even talk to them anymore
well god bless your life no no but thank
you
just one one thing you said the kukui
that's what they used to call me out on
the streets when i was working really
yeah i was the kukui that's what they
used to hear because if you're a
criminal then i want to see you
yeah right there that's the god my
partner was green eyes and i was a kukui
what was your nickname george um
that scene and where do we start
rockhead
oh but my grandpa called me uh encanto
which was the term of endearment
but i didn't take it as a terminator
because
i i didn't know what a tournament
dearman was i thought it was i thought
he was [ __ ]
there there's no way this is a good
thing it's the best thing
like you know so momo you know momo and
this guy aj
barrera they're a little bit into the
they you know their
intuitives and uh momo was at my house
there's no way that momo knows this and
he says i
feel he goes what is uh who who called
you in kanto
and i said i said hey man why did you
say that why why
why did you say that no no like
something just came to me and said like
i said my grandfather called me that and
nobody knows that that's the difference
between me and you
somebody said that at my house and say
y'all bet they're coming
i'm telling you but you know i named my
first company that
and you know there's no there's an
encounter i'm like is there an account
i think no there's not that's that's
that's going to be a special show
yeah super premium right there yeah that
you know i can draw too so
but i mean this is uh hey isn't she
great
she is this is uh this is the nicest
courageous and and there's so much
intelligence so much that is so much
power has come out and we're very
profound stuff
i'm uh what i would want mine i think i
could say that because mine doesn't
listen but what i would inspire mine to
be
don't worry we'll clip this out but
we're going to be best friends on the
show absolutely
so absolutely nbc if you're watching we
uh are starting to already cast
unbeknownst i know how to do it i can do
it if i've done it once
i can do it again i mean she's when you
meet somebody that you know is
it is amazing and i think for clubhouse
like
i told somebody i told you guys that the
first time i did it
i was talking i didn't know i was
talking about colonoscopies and you know
they're as like well you know you gotta
you once you turn 40 you got like every
five years you gotta go and then
somebody sent me a message hey man
everybody can hear you and that's why
they're hearing now they know you gotta
you know get colonoscopies but
it it's uh i didn't realize how
i think it's better for us
than instagram and twitter because it is
me telling you what my truth is
or what good advice is when
on instagram and twitter it isn't about
good advice if it is about or tick tock
it's about
somebody talked me into going on
instagram and
and the criticism is new to you right
well the criticism
doesn't bother me because people say you
should be used to that yeah if you don't
if you don't acknowledge criticism i
like what you said the little message
that i
sent you today if you don't acknowledge
what somebody says
then you're the winner not them because
they're trying to get
a reaction out of you so that's been my
whole thing what do they call that
uh what's the word for that like
somebody criticized critics christ they
said
hey man [ __ ] off and then they got what
are they called
yeah well they want they want to get
that the poking
no but it's the poking right pulling
something
is a good one yeah i feel like charlie
my mom used to always compare it so i'm
sure you all played tetherball growing
up oh yeah yeah okay so my mom was like
the tetherball champ
of the yard and her biggest thing
because she used to tell me that when i
was little because
you know being a light-skinned latina i
would always be teased for being a
coconut and people would say that i was
brown
on the outside you had to be above it
yeah no
no no no they couldn't reach it yeah
no so what she would say is so they
would call me a coconut because they
would say it was brown on the outside
and white on the inside which i just
thought was ridiculous because i wanted
to study not only it was a great thing
it's a great term
by the way yeah thanks
thanks george george is my new brulee
amazing um
so she would be like but here's the
thing here's what you do she's like this
was always my trick when people would
you know throw the ball
i would get it and i would figure out
where i was going to aim to your point
aim higher but i would hold the ball if
i didn't want to play and if i was done
playing and i just wanted to take the
win i would drop the bomb walk away
so when someone throws something at you
and they love either hate or their
security or their issues
hold the ball if you throw the ball back
you're giving them the attention
and you're going to play the game
exactly if you don't play the game
the game is over you win you walk away
i'm like hey
all right yeah well that is way more
complicated than what i said to gil
i said uh we don't respond to that [ __ ]
cause zero people know who that is and
we're above it i'm not
i'm not gonna most likely have a latino
who's a
social influencer right
uh be with us and influence people so
there you go and there's a
yes beef squasher uh reference and let's
go watch here
and you know we don't yeah we don't so
this instagram stuff
uh i've got a bunch of followers and
then
there's some very nice people on there
but there's also now
probably a good minimally 100 200 people
that are
richard ramirez fans oh
groupies oh yeah do you get groupies oh
yeah yeah so i i got groupies on there
and i just keep deleting them you know
i just keep
if the killers get the groupies i still
don't understand how richard got married
which is just weird to me
but if the killers get groupies i might
think like you as a detective could get
some groupies because i know you get
groupies yeah
so i can only imagine i mean did that
ever impact your
marriage or relationship with anne well
no they're not groupies like that you
know
listen when they're latinas i had more
people that wanted to feed me than [ __ ]
me
so you know they would bring they would
bring
food to the house and they would bring
cakes and i don't throw them in the
trash but it was like she's like you're
going to poison listen
you can [ __ ] him but if you feed him
he'll come back to you
but if he [ __ ] you he that's the last
time you're going to never hear from him
again i remember arsenio said to
somebody that i was hanging out with
they said hey listen if you ever want
george to leave you alone just tell me
you love him he'll take off
so uh uh i was like
the food was the way because you know
the food is to me
with your heart what's more pleasurable
i just think the flavor the way that i
saw
of relationships i don't appreciate a
good relationship
mm-hmm that's fair it wasn't muddled
it's almost like if you're if you're
drying and you grab somebody that's
beautiful it's ankle like hey
[ __ ] let go of me
i'm not going down there with you like i
fall by myself so you know it's careful
who you
i was always careful about who i
associated would associate with whether
for the good or
for where the better for them because
i was going to probably tell them it's
not a good idea because i'm not
going to be there entirely because i'm
going to disappear at some point
but at least i understand it and i
haven't been able to you know
get through it and the groupies i've
never had
like that all good yeah i've never had
no ruby i mean look they take a little
71 year old man overweight retired
you never know i'm just telling you it's
not that there's like a
a thing like why would someone be you
know attracted to wanting to get with
charles manson with richard yeah richard
they they want to have this baby
yes the menendez brothers
i mean immediately i mean immediately
you said when they when they
captured them and you guys took them
from holland back down to down to
where that the woman opened her oh yeah
she was going out that's the story of
what the perp walk was i want to know
the perp walk story from when you took
them out of holland back because they
did
we took them out of holland back went
straight to cars we had cops all around
us it was like
presidential thousand people you know
they had people back that helicopters
over us motors in front of us
motorbiking crazy
cop car said as we're driving down the
street away from holland back some lady
it was like a mako truck like a panel
truck where they sell tools out of
she's on top of the panel truck she
opens up and she's swinging
and i said there you are rich those are
for you brother you know they're not for
me
they're for you so they're they're
people who are all kind of stuff
and he was what did he say he didn't say
nothing
he didn't say nothing well you know he
said that once he got captured like
all the kind of emotion leaves right
because their power is being cheated
and being chased yeah like they they wat
they watch the news they read the paper
they're looking for their name well i
don't know how he didn't know that he
was in every paper when he came back
from the bus
well it went and he went out friday he
was on a bus
traveling back from arizona yeah or he
who his brother didn't see him right now
he didn't
see him so we put it out friday night
here
okay he's on a bus coming back from
arizona
he gets back saturday morning and then
that's when he sees his picture
so fun fact my uncle was a block away
also lived in islos
uh was a block away from where he got
captured
to like also make sure that he got in
and he was like honestly if the cops
hadn't showed up they would have killed
him right there
he's like they were not going to let him
go they weren't going to let him go but
there was a nice people that got him and
i said
gosh he's like the closer it got to
nightfall the more we were like could
have been
if it had been the people from the
barrio you know the for sure the banger
they'd have
is that paul still there oh yeah where's
the car
anybody have the head wrap and that jack
daniel's shirt
any of those things the jack daniel's
shirt big
deal people ask me so many times where
is the show where is the show
the jack daniels shirt the biggest
question is where's the jack dancing
where's the jackpot and did he smell
like a goat
you know no the people need to know
okay but where is the shirt though why
why i have no i have no idea it's still
in evidence or
no he never got out it wouldn't be in
evidence we we took
everything that he had it was placed in
evidence right
whatever we used for the
court process was submitted so they
would have
possession of everything that was
submitted for court as court evidence so
it's lost somewhere yeah and
we would have anything that was not
submitted right
so what they will do eventually somebody
because i don't work there anymore uh
there is no more appeals process or
no more civil process there's no more
nothing somebody's going to sit there
and say
let's just get rid of it let's destroy
it do you know that there's a
evidence locker at the courthouse i
don't know
there's an evidence locker in the
courthouse that
is evidence from as far back as i don't
see any names
the 60s 70s 80s
all there gun ropes
evidence uh tagged
do they let you see it in this closet
and it's closed
to the public only if you're vip georgia
because you can no i probably couldn't
get it
uh it's like when they make you go in
the naked you know they used to
do pills so like in new jack city you
know you couldn't steal
you walk in their neck and so they make
sure you don't leave wearing a jack down
but there's an evidence locker in there
that is from the
from the past so that it's probably
interesting because it wouldn't be
thrown away i don't believe
well some of the stuff you know like i
was just asked within the last
five five months they had a chair the
chair that richard sat in every day in
court
oh said do you want it asking me the
courts are asking me do i want the chair
did you take it you tell them that
george wants it no one
no i said no you know i told you i said
energy they're they're asking me if i
want the chair my wife said
you're bringing that exactly with that
energy
and saying i made arrangements to get it
over to the sheriff's museum
oh that's true so they'll keep it there
but there that was stuff just held by
the court that's not in evidence
because that was not part of the case
that's just reset but gil okay so here's
the thing i'm on a mission i want to get
george into the smithsonian definitely
with an nft but i also feel like if
there's other evidence
i feel like we also need to put you in
the latin um smithsonian
in dc because you were the first latino
i know you're super humble about it
but i feel like we should either get the
chair or get something else figure that
in
out with like your picture there we need
to submit it to the latino smithsonian
i appreciate i'll tell you my the socks
that i wore in high school still fit so
that everything else is good
okay uh nobody knows this i went to see
bill cosby at the tulare state fair
in the late 90s and he did the
show with a chair that there wasn't a
chair and they said well what do you
need he said i need you know like a
little place to put my cigar
and i need a chair and they went to the
office and they got
a metal chair with green vinyl back and
a green
vinyl seat and i
took the chair and i still haven't
you don't want to throw it out after the
whole i haven't even thought about it
until right now
that's your limitations up don't matter
yeah it's yours wait a minute
how did you walk out with the chair were
you just like pretending you were a
maintenance man like
no i was there you know i was kind of in
you know
but maybe let's see
give it yeah all right so
how was this graham beautiful huh this
is great you still look at your watch
cover
no no like i said that was just the
command to uh get killed a little lower
left so he could get his beautiful face
on the frame that was all
i love it wait so go tell me did he
really say
when they gave him his conviction that
death is nothing and he was going to go
to or i'll see you at disneyland yeah
he said that as he's walking out of the
courthouse into his transportation
but he wasn't uh was he an intellectual
no he was he was just kind of more about
you he was welcome
like like okay you know like they just
kind of like
would just pick at you and say something
to you the guy was you know people asked
that and
and he was it was a mutual respect i was
a homicide cop he was a murder suspect
and we
respected each other he was good at his
craft and i was good at minecraft thank
god you were better
and so yeah and i told them hey the guys
in white watching movies
guys with white hats always win you know
you guys don't so
we're going to do this rich and he
called me gil i called him rich and
that's the way we got along he wasn't he
was well ready and
he says i've got an ego that will fill
this room he said i'll tell you
everything from the time the romans fed
the christians to the lions the modern
day serial killers
so he was an articulate individual so is
there
is there a statement that like you ever
think of or that like haunts you that
you're like gosh
i really wonder what he meant by that or
like why didn't i catch that sooner
because that was maybe a clue or a
giveaway that he no
i love that not at all but hail satan
that hail thing still still chills with
the hand
with the hand and oh no that was too
much
and then writing it on the what was the
big what was the big uh
floor he did it he did it on the floor
he did it on the desk he was doing this
and when i called him on it i said fill
it in and he didn't he said what i said
fill it in
he said well the pentagram i said that
[ __ ] doesn't bother me rich and he's
erased it there's nothing there but he
racing but [ __ ] might like uh
like mine those games yeah games
everything's
everything's a [ __ ] mind it was yeah
we had to we were playing each other
yeah it was a game of chess
what was the clue that the jewelry that
he took that guy that san francisco
were the informer guys and the shoes
wouldn't give them
a shoe everything came together at the
same time the shoes got thrown away
somewhere
i didn't know that that over the golden
gate bridge ritz room over the golden
gate
i didn't know because uh diane feinstein
oh yeah can we talk about her because i
was bitter grapes that like she was the
mayor
said they said don't tell her not to say
it yes
don't say it and she did it yeah
and he heard of course he heard i don't
know what the reason was maybe
up one up i can only imagine you must
have been
so liberated
oh because that even even when the
reporters went over there and the guy
was watering the grass he goes oh is
this about that dude that writes on the
walls
exactly that too and that guy was that
guy work for the police department no
were the guy's watering the grass and he
sees them there
and they go what are they doing there oh
and they tell laurel erickson and that
guy
yeah henry alfaro and laurel lyrics
goldnick was there paul scholnick and
they go
oh they're probably there at that house
because of the guy that writes on the
walls
and then when they came out they said
what about the guy that ready to go you
know
you could just see their demeanor change
we're out
we're good yeah nature
this is very like tech forward episode
so people people will i think it's kind
of like an emotion sorry yeah yeah yeah
it was technically deep emotion yeah
you know yeah we don't want any accident
thank you if you got a bounce you got
about well i still got my
oh and i want to thank tyler um good
seeing the brother
i think it's to loafy no it's not what's
his name say right
to loafy how do you say it's whoever
gave you the goods
toffely to foley to foley not toffley
to what did i say to loafy telophia
my man was a king won the championship
with the king went to
canada and played i think with winnipeg
maybe
and then got traded to the canadians
went to the finals and did not
win but he went to the finals and
he gifted me this let's see because
it's beautiful i got a kings once i
didn't sign it
but that's all right and you know check
this out
in my heart of hearts when i was growing
up
i didn't really i watched hockey a
little bit
but i always liked this jersey it's
amazing that they would send it to me
because
yeah it would have been one i would have
bought for myself
well don't tell him that now don't tell
him that now don't check it out
amazing it's great destiny there another
one
god with this manifest destiny he's
working up
we're done
you